has really stepped up in the second half
d.a contesting the shot from d rose and
then
taj gibson just throwing
an elbow into the back of chris paul
he's talking to tips too i mean they
know each other from usa basketball
chris paul just turned 36 and taj gibson
at 35.
well it wouldn't be the first time the
suns and nicks have mixed it up
monty williams pulling him away but
there you see underneath
gibson comes down on paul and then
throws an elbow into him
it looked like gibson was almost upset
that paul had boxed him out
of the rebound you look at it here
gibson jumping over him possible
now he probably feels he was undercut a
little bit but gibson throws that
shoulder right into chris paul but
chris paul he does a great job he always
walks away from any kind of
confrontation but
he's telling tibs yeah he threw an elbow
at me
[Applause]
and again your emotions and the heat of
the moment when things happen
chris paul is saying don't tell me what
you what you did or didn't do